[Musique]
julie du à lui casimir qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour ton jour je voudrais
acheter quelque chose oui tout ce que tu
veux à condition que ça existe dans la
boutique bon gars tu vois je me prépare
à un gloubi boulga tant tactiques
seulement j'ai j'ai pas tout ce qu'il
faut ah oui mais s'ils sont des
saucisses de toulouse suis désolé mais
alors avec la réduction des importations
journée non ça les saucisses de toulouse
j'en ai j'ai fait des réserves
alors si de la moutarde non la moutarde
ça va j'en ai peut-être même mis un peu
trop bon vaty frasier pas dit ce qu'il
manque au lieu de jouer aux devinettes
comme ça voilà public alors j'ai aussi
les bananes j'ai mis la confiture de
fraises ce qu'il me manque c'est le
chocolat en poudre à face à jean nuit
tant mieux voilà voilà comme ça on
attend encore un peu ton corps voila
voila tu sur des proportions quoi les
quais clé les croire sio si simple si le
rapport de commuter entre les différents
produits qui composent de blue biblia
non mais il n'y a pas de problème
regarde j'ai mis un quart de bananes un
quart de saucisse de toulouse un quart
de moutards un quart de confiture de
fraise et puis un regard de chocolat en
poudre à didot il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas regardons 13 moutarde chocolat
banane saucisse de toulouse ça fait cinq
produits tu peux pas mettre un quart de
chaque produit il n'y a que quatre
quarts dans le blue bulgare ah oui oui
non mais avec 5 car ça montre un plus
gros athena qui gagne au lieu d'un
gloubiboulga normal j'ai un gros
gloubiboulga repartez ça allez au revoir
et merci à lille
saleh casimir bonjour toi que tu m'as
l'air bien gai aujourd'hui ouais ouais
je suis en train de préparer un gloubi
boulga tellement gros qu'il aura 5 1 en
voyant casimir une chose peut avoir
comme 4/4 citons gloubiboulga et est
petit il aura quatre petits car
maintenant s'il est gros il aura quatre
drones armés mais quatre seulement je
veux bien qu'il n'est qu'au 4 car si
c'est des très gros quart mais je les
mange la campagne tous les cinq
occasions
tu es désespéré dis moi tu veux me faire
plaisir
ouais comment et bain avec une petite
danse beenox
oui tu sais j'aime beaucoup tant qu'anti
dans ce qui est le danseur le plus
gracieux que je connaisse c'est vrai je
suis un bon danseur
j'aime bien d'autant plus que j'ai une
nouvelle danse regardez pas la part la
pop en passant par casimir c'était
merveilleux merci
tiens voilà tu peux aller manger
maintenant moins d'accord ah oui c'est
vrai j'y pense j'ai une lettre pour toi
ah bon attends attends attends la voici
voilà voilà quasiment selah sue le
gloubiboulga bon voilà à lire et tout à
l'heure malaisie casimir salut françois
j'ai des courriers pour vous deux
j'avais vu casimir et il est vraiment
drôle pas vrai mais dites-moi facteurs
il me semble vous avoir entendu les
dires il était un excellent danseur si
je lui dis que ça me fait rigoler il
faudra plus jamais dansé alors ça à
celle là et pour julie apprenez à
françois laisser b tiens on dirait
l'imprimé publicitaire voyons madame
monsieur c'est un grand jour qui
s'annonce pour vous un jour qui changera
votre vie vous allez découvrir le gloubi
bout vous allez découvrir le
gloubiboulga qu'est ce qui se cache
derrière ce nom mystérieux vous le
saurez quand je viendrai vous rendre
visite mois anatole dur offre un
inventeur du gloubiboulga mais il faut
absolument prévenir casimir c'est un
apple dürfen elle lui a volé son idée
quand je cours le chercher l'inventeur
du gloubiboulga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voila voila je vous ramène casimir et
ben la lettre que je lui ai donné était
aussi une publicité pour le gloubiboulga
oh oui mais c'est scandaleux ce bassin
il veut me vendre mon double bogey au
monteur casimir casinos terrestres car
je me présente un acteur du refrain
inventeur du loup monsieur anatole du
refrain calme-toi casimir
je vais aller droit au but nous savons
tous ici que vous n'êtes pas l'inventeur
du gloubiboulga nous dire ça et bien
notre ami casimir ici présents mois on a
reçu la recette de sanaa non quand il
était tout petit vous vous le dire que
monsieur connaissait la recette depuis
des années exactement
mesut épouvantable mais je suis revenu
j'ai une idée vous continuez à vendre
mon gloubiboulga êtes-vous membres frais
tous les jours de grands bols pour moi
tout seul
d'accord c'est une excellente idée mais
c'est halimi remarche contenu tope-là va
très bien comme ça tout est en ordre
je voudrais quand même vous poser une
question
ben je vous écoute que comptez-vous
faire tous les jours avec deux grandes
bol de lotion pour les cheveux quoi
votre gloubiboulga c'est de la lotion
pour les chevaux évidemment oui
[Musique]